facebook heeded michelle obama's call
they have now banned donald trump from
facebook and instagram
from zuckerberg quote we believe the
risks of allowing the president
to continue to use our service during
this period are simply
too great therefore we are extending the
block we have placed on his facebook and
instagram accounts
indefinitely and for at least the next
two weeks
until the peaceful transition of power
is complete
so big tech
in collusion with the liberal
establishment michelle obama
hard to get more liberal establishment
than that
is now banning censoring
the duly elected president nobody has
elected
michelle obama nobody ever elected
michelle obama
i guess she was part of the package with
barack but he's not in office anymore
nobody elected mark zuckerberg to
anything
the only person in this whole
circumstance who has been elected
through our constitutional process is
donald trump
and he's the one being censored at the
behest of the others
it's not just the censorship on facebook
though
he's no longer allowed to engage in
commerce
shopify has banned president trump
his campaign any of his organizations
from using their service to process
payments
he's being the duly elected president
being ostracized from commerce they
write quote
based on recent events we have
determined that the actions by president
donald j
trump violate our acceptable use policy
which prohibits promotion or supportive
organizations
platforms or people that threaten or
condone violence to further a cause
as a result we have terminated stores
affiliated
with president trump
this is this is unprecedented this is
extremely dangerous much more historic
and dangerous than any of the events
that we've been talking about
really even over the last few months
they're not after him they're after
you and me and this is going to have
we've seen this happen to prominent
conservatives
they just pick one off and they say well
hopefully we won't care
oh the circumstances meredith they've
been trying to pick off trump now for
for four years five years
and now they think this is a good moment
where we can totally de-platform him and
censor him
and you're going to hear squishy
conservatives say well and i don't even
call them conservatives squishy
republican types they'll say
well look trump can just make his own
e-commerce platform
well trump can make his own largest
social media network in the world
no no well we only care about government
censorship no if the god if
someone is completely ostracized from
society i don't care
if it's the government doing it or some
oligarchs in silicon valley doing it in
cahoots with the liberal establishment
that is an urgent problem
not just them in addition to
social media and e-commerce kicking off
president trump we now have simon
schuster major major publisher
canceling senator josh hawley's book
josh hawley was writing a book
coincidentally on big tech tyranny
and because josh hawley followed the
constitutional process
to object to some of the electors in
this election
because of election irregularities simon
schuster is canceling his book
on the unrelated topic of big tech they
write quote we did not come to this
decision lightly yeah okay
as a publisher it will always be our
mission to amplify a variety of voices
and viewpoints
at the same time we take seriously our
larger public responsibility as citizens
and cannot support senator hawley after
his role
in what became a dangerous threat to our
democracy and freedom
what was josh hawley's role
josh hawley's role in the dangerous
threat to our but also what dangerous
threat toward democracy and freedom
the the riot at the capitol very bad
very ugly
people are going to be punished as they
should be
this was not a coup d'etat this was
larping this was a decadent
mob playing a live-action video game
they went in and took silly pictures in
nancy pelosi's office
there was no new constitution there was
no declaration of new representatives
they just went in and messed up some
stuff in the capitol and
and left the threat to our democracy
what like this is the
russian revolution or something give me
a break
this is an excuse by simon schuster to
ban conservatives
what did hawley do did hawley go out and
say
because frankly if josh harley went out
there and said hey we need to go storm
the capital right now i
actually could understand the decision
it's pretty bad stuff you don't be
associated with that
that's not what he did he followed the
constitutional process
to challenge electors after an
unprecedented election
in which all of the safeguards of
election integrity were upended
weeks and maybe months before the
election we've never seen anything like
it
in certain cases in pennsylvania notably
in explicit violation of the state
constitution
yeah i think it's okay to object i think
it's okay to follow the legal process in
that case
nope not not according to simon schuster
well look michael if you if you don't
want if you want to read josh hawley's
book you already just found your own
publishing house
no this is so profoundly naive
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
[Music]
you